[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
ED HUSAIN: Thank you,
Alice, for welcoming me here
and for organizing this.
Thank you to all of
you for making time
on a very warm, sunny
London lunchtime.
I appreciate it.
I'll speak for about
25, 30 minutes.
I'll steer towards the 25
rather than the 30 minutes.
And I'm interested in
what you have to say,
questions you have to
ask, and reflections,
thoughts, criticisms.
I wrote the book because,
since 9/11 up until now,
almost every Muslim
conversation or conversation
with Islam and Muslims
in the public domain
seems to be dominated
by extremism, terrorism,
fanaticism, fundamentalism,
radicalism, and it's negative.
And while I understand,
and I think most of us
understand, why that happens,
the lived reality of Muslims
is something entirely different.
And the lived history of a
civilization for the last 1,400
years is entirely different.
And I have two
young daughters now,
and my attitude
towards this issue
is, well, how is their
world being shaped?
And that's what concerns
me, the next generation
and the generation after that.
And I fear that comments
from the current White House
or what we've seen play out
at the U.N. or the media drive
that we have focuses entirely on
the extremism and the violence,
but misses a much deeper,
more colorful nuanced history
of coexistence,
peace, compassion.
And I try to bring
that out in the book.
And I bring it out
not by theory and not
by what I think
ought to be told,
but by drawing on
real life Muslims
who lived in the seventh
century, eighth century,
ninth century, almost
every century down
to the last century.
There's no one from this
century featured in the book.
I mean, it's 19,
20, 18 years old.
But Hassan al-Banna, the founder
of the Muslim Brotherhood,
a prominent name, probably
the most influential Arab,
he features in one
of the chapters.
Now one of the most important
things about the book,
in my view, is
that it highlights
two or three elements that
most Muslims think about, live,
reflect on, and try to
act on on a daily basis,
but doesn't have any
mainstream echoing.
And the first focus is--
and what I'm saying
isn't made up.
It's genuine.
It's from someone who's
lived for 40 plus years now,
is a Muslim born into a Muslim
household, lived in the Middle
East, Syria, and Saudi
Arabia, traveled extensively
across the Muslim
world, from Morocco
all the way to Indonesia and
down further on to Bahrain.
And so what I'm saying is
based on both live reality
and what we find
in our scriptures.
The overwhelming focus
in Muslim history,
the overwhelming
emphasis in Muslim life,
and what you'll see the
majority of the Muslim scholars
throughout history emphasize
is a huge focus on love.
And when I say love,
I mean love for God,
love for God's creation,
love for your spouse's, love
for architecture, love for
beauty, love for the divine.
And the queue for
that comes right
from the beginning
of Muslim history
when the Quran was
revealed to the prophet
Muhammad There's a verse.
There are multiple
verses, but there's
one that comes to my
mind now, you know?
[NON-ENGLISH PHRASE] That if
you truly claim to love God,
then follow me.
So the prophet
Muhammad is trying
to guide people to a way in
which they can love the divine.
And stemming from that love
is a 1,400 year old tradition
of trying to honor that love.
And I go into that in
the book in great detail
to show how there's an
emphasis on loving the divine,
and from that loving, the
creation of the divine,
and from that stems loving
for what is yet to come.
So that, you know, the
Burkin analysis of we
are all inheritors of the
past, and we preserve it.
And then we pass the baton
onto a younger generation.
That's an inherent
Muslim concept
from the very beginning.
Now maintaining that
tradition focused on love
has an implication.
And that implication is the
third point I try to bring out,
and that's emulation, emulation
of those who we claim to love.
And often that's instinctive.
Often that's taught.
But most Muslims,
especially Muslim men,
try to emulate the prophet
Muhammad And in that
comes the excess, in that
comes some of the extremism,
and in that also comes some of
the balance and the antidote
to the extremism
and the terrorism
and the fanaticism that
tilts the conversation in one
direction.
So the Taj Mahal, for example,
most people around the world
know it, but they don't
appreciate the fact
that this was a symbol of
love from a Muslim monarch
to his deceased wife
that was designed
to ensure that that tradition
was passed on to generations
until eternity.
And the Taj Mahal isn't alone.
In the tomb built
by a Muslim monarch
for his beloved similar
architectural achievements
you will find almost in every
Muslim town and city and indeed
even villages, the
Sufis in particular,
and I'll come to
that in a moment.
But, yes, there's
a good news story,
but I don't want to ignore
the negative and the fringe
activity.
And I just want to
quickly touch on
that before I turn to some of
the other themes in the book.
One of the biggest struggles
that we've had here
in the West and
the Western press,
but also in our
governments, here
and also in the Muslim
East, is the inability
to articulate what
the problem is.
So if you say it's
Islamist extremism,
a whole group of
people get upset,
because the word
Islam is in there.
If you say it's jihadism,
another group of people
get upset, because the
word jihad is in there.
And so we're almost
paralyzed at a policy level
as to how we address this
difficult topic without naming
and shaming the enemy and
without, therefore, governments
being able to deal
with the problem.
What I've tried to do is
explain what Islamism is.
Essentially, it
is an outcome of--
you know, David Goodhart
reviewed the book on Saturday,
and he picked up on this,
that the destruction
of the German empire, or
the Austro-Hungarian empire,
the Prussians led to
the creation of Nazism.
The German feeling of defeat,
humiliation, loss, and the need
to reinstate what Plato calls
thumos, or self-recognition,
self-worth, that led to Nazism.
The destruction of
the Russian Empire
led to the formation
of communism,
and the Soviet Union reemerging
as trying to reinstate some
of that old glory from Moscow.
The destruction of
the Ottoman Empire,
the Muslim empire that
the Turks controlled,
led to the birth of Islamism.
And so it's almost trackable
that the destruction
of large empires
and their peoples
feeling loss,
humiliation, degradation,
then emerges in this ugly
manifestation of extremism
in those various excesses.
Now Islamism was a reaction
to that humiliating
loss of Muslim power.
For 1,000 years, Muslims
were the global superpower
in various empires.
For 1,000 years, Muslims
did not seek to convert.
And this is documented
by John of Damascus
who saw the early Arab
armies coming into Damascus.
And they don't seek to convert.
And many of the Christians
in Damascus and Egypt
in the seventh and eighth
centuries wished to convert.
But the Muslim elite
ruling class, the Arabs,
generally say,
well, don't convert,
because we're not
here to convert you.
We're quite happy you
paying an extra levy of tax,
and, you know, we benefit
from that taxation.
And that goes into our
treasury or our coffer.
So the initial impulse
was not to convert.
And I'd say to
this day, the fact
that in large countries
such as India--
and there are others in Africa.
Nigeria comes to mind-- where
we've had Muslim governments
and empires, but we
still have large numbers
of people who are not Muslims.
So there was not
an attempt to force
and to convert by the sword.
Peter Frankopan, who Alice
and I were just talking about,
refers to this in his book,
how it wasn't an impulse
to convert by force.
But the story of Islamism
is in the modern world
that loss of that political
power, that superpower
status around the world has led
to Muslims wanting to convert,
wanting to impose, wanting to
show power and recognition,
and worse.
And sometimes that is done
through the most extreme ways,
which is extremism, terrorism.
But sometimes that's done
through innovative ways.
And you may call it
emulative innovation,
but the Emirates
are great at that.
The fact that the Burj
tower is the tallest
tower in the world
in Dubai, the fact
that the most expensive
hotel is now in Dubai,
the fact that the World Cup
is being hosted in Qatar,
there is an impulse there in
the Gulf to want to compete,
to want to be the best.
You may criticize it on
a whole range of levels.
But that impulse to be the best,
whether it's having the largest
sovereign wealth fund in the
world, the Abu Dhabi Investment
Fund, that impulse
still remains.
And that impulse finds
extreme manifestation
through jihadists and others.
Now, I just want to deal
with the extremism problem,
because it might be
festering in your head
on the definitional front, and
then move on to other issues.
And I touch on all of
these issues in the book.
But who is an Islamist?
You know, we talk about
them often in the news,
but very few people
provide a definition.
When you look at 1,300
years of Muslim history,
I'll give an example
from the Ottomans.
For 700 years, the Ottomans
were the superpower
in the bulk of the Middle East.
They knocked on the
doors of Vienna twice.
They maintained an
imperial presence
from Albania, the Balkans, all
the way down to parts of Yemen.
They only had one incident
of stoning an adulterer.
This Old Testament and Quranic
punishment of adultery,
there was only one incident.
What that proves to us
is that what the Ottoman
and Muslim empires
did not do is make
what was Haram,
what is religiously
forbidden for religiously
observant people.
This is a key issue.
They did not make halal and
Haram, what's religiously
forbidden, what's
religiously sanctioned,
they did not make that
personal act state law.
It did not become
legal or illegal.
So if you drank alcohol for
most Muslims and most Muslim
scholars it's considered to
be forbidden to drink alcohol,
but it's not illegal.
So if you are caught
drinking alcohol,
you're not a criminal who's
going to be thrown into prison,
prosecuted, and punished.
And that's a key distinction
that we have missed.
And by the way, most
Muslims and most Muslim
communities have homosexuality.
I'm not saying most
Muslims have homosexuality.
I'm saying most Muslim
countries have homosexuality,
as it is in most countries.
But it wasn't an issue.
In 1857, the Ottomans,
1857, early on the Ottomans
decriminalized it.
They made it an
individual choice.
Pretty early on, I
think 100 years or so
before we did so in the west.
The point I'm trying
to make is Islamists
want the halal and
the Haram, what's
religiously forbidden
for an individual,
to become state law.
In other words, the government
intervenes in your life.
For 1,000 years, Muslims didn't
have that very government
driven, Marxist, control all
elements of your life fixation.
It's a very modern obsession
that halal and Haram
must become legal and illegal.
If you're are a sinner--
and we're all sinners as
the Archbishop of Canterbury
is keen to point out.
If you're a sinner,
you're not just a sinner.
You're also a criminal.
Now that distinction
is what we miss,
and that distinction is what
Islamists want us to blur.
So whether it's the Muslim
Brotherhood in the Middle East
or the Jamaat-e-Islami in
the Indian subcontinent,
they want to create
governments that
make individual acts of
religiously sanctioned or not
legal and illegal.
That's Iran today.
Hence the fixation with
wearing a headscarf.
There are scriptural
encouragements for Muslims,
and I would argue, Jewish
women to cover their hair.
You see Christian women when
they go to see the Pope,
they cover their hair.
Now that's a choice.
If people want to do
it, good for them.
They don't want to do
it, brilliant to them.
But the Iranian government
wants to impose it.
That's Islamism.
Islamist movements
are a new development.
They've been around since 1928.
We didn't have those
in our history.
So Islamism is about
creating an Islamic state,
an Islamic government.
Now some of them want
to compete in elections.
They often lose.
The problem becomes
is then when they
fail to achieve their
Islamist, stroke Marxist state,
other than in Iran
currently, then what
happens is they take up force.
So ISIS was all about
bringing that vision by force.
Because the population
isn't Muslim enough,
we will take up arms and create
an Islamic state by force.
So this is what we
call the jihadis,
you know, the jihadist impulse.
They use force to advance
the Islamist worldview.
Now I want to give you one last
example of this kind of rot
and problem within Islam, and
then move on to other issues.
And that is in early
Islam, we also had this.
Now my contention is
that all great ideas,
in history or in
the modern world,
also have an ugly side to it.
There's an excess.
So patriotism and
loving your own country
is, in and of
itself, a good thing.
You know, it creates virtue
of dedication, of sacrifice,
of protection, and a common
notion of citizenship.
In and of itself,
patriotism is a good thing.
But taken to its
extreme, whether it's
the UKIP version
or the EDL version
or the America First version,
or its other extreme,
you know the Nazism and
the fascism that manifests,
it's a problem.
So Islam as a body of ideas
and, as a Muslim I believe,
a form of revelation from God,
also has this extreme problem.
And that extreme
problem from very early
on was something called
a Khawarij movement.
Now Khawarij comes from
the Arabic word that is
to [NON-ENGLISH] which means
[NON-ENGLISH] or to exit,
to leave.
And the movement
was called as such,
they were called a Khawarij
by early Muslims, companions
of the prophet,
cousins of the prophet.
The fourth Caliph
encountered them.
Now without going into
a huge amount of detail,
because all of that
appears in the book,
is that the Khawarij took
up arms against the majority
of Muslims.
And their contention
was that most Muslims
who accepted arbitration
of men, human beings,
were not pious believers.
So they took up arms
and wanted to kill
the fourth Caliph, Imam Ali.
And in that very early
battle what happens
is Imam Ali and others expel
them from within Islam.
They say, you are not believers.
And I bring the
evidence in the book
to prove why they
were not believers.
It in other words,
they did not belong
to the community of Muslims.
That's why they were
called Khawarij.
Now historically, whenever the
Khawarij movement appeared,
either the Ottomans
or the Mughals
normally eradicated
them by force,
because they were
called treasonous.
They sowed dissension.
They killed other--
They were made to disappear.
The problem in the
modern world is
we can't do that, because we
have human rights concerns.
We have torture concerns.
And rightly, you wouldn't
want to go and kill
entire groups of people because
they believe in taking up
arms against governments.
That said, the Egyptians
have done that.
The Libyans have done that.
With Iraq, they emerged
from around the region.
The Khawarij emerged.
And they venerate
the old Khawarij.
They make the same claims.
Their appearance is the same.
Even Ibn Abbas, one of
the prophet's most close
companions, went to see
the group of Khawarij
in the seventh century.
And it's astounding that he
walks into their encampment.
And he looks at 6,000 of
them, and he meets them all.
Ibn Abbas, the prophet's, one
of his most dear companions.
And Ibn Abbas was
very well-dressed.
He was wearing perfume.
They used to have long
hair in those days.
His beard was trimmed.
And he wore a Yemeni robe.
He walked into the encampment
of the Khawarij who'd taken up
arms against the Caliph.
And he said, I don't
see a single companion
of the prophet among you.
And the Khawarij say,
because they're all mistaken.
And then he asks them,
what is their mistake?
And they give a list of
three or four things.
And one of the things
they say to him
is that your appearance
is a problem to us.
And he looks at them, and he
wrote about this afterwards,
and he thought their appearance
was a problem to him.
It's all in the book.
But what I want to very
quickly mention to you
is the similarities.
In that, they were
very rough people.
They had these
massive prayer marks.
Prayer mark, I'm being polite.
But they had these kind of--
what's the expression when
you have a health issue,
because you've been
prostrating for too long
and rubbing your
forehead on the floor?
You see that in Egypt
a lot, by the way.
So they had that mark.
Their beards were
long and messy.
Their clothes were rough.
Their hands, and
they smelt badly.
And he made this observation.
And their observation to
him was the entire opposite.
You're a profit
of the companion,
why are you so well-dressed?
And why are you so well groomed?
And his response was, my
prophet encouraged us,
Muhammad encouraged us
to wear the best clothes.
Dress as the Yemenis.
Those Yemenis were
the most well-dressed
and the Romans were the
well-dressed at that time,
so he encouraged that.
He had a Roman shirt,
an Italian shirt.
Does that go down as
Armani these days?
I don't know.
But so he, Ibn Abbas
was acting on that.
And they acting on something
completely opposite,
this rough and rugged way.
Move among the ISIS people,
move among the extreme Muslims
today, whether the
Salifis in Brixton mosque
or whether you go down to
Hizb al-Nour in Alexandria
or whether you go down and see
them in [? Najd, ?] I mean,
I've met them, and
I've seen them,
and they have those same traits.
You know, their appearance
is rough and ragged.
They're misogynists.
They're judgmental people.
But above all, they
have violent tendencies,
and they are extremely
firm in their convictions,
that they are on
capital T truth.
And for that, they
are willing to kill.
So Ibn Abbas confronts them.
He has a whole debate with them.
And that's also in the book.
So the Khawarij, the
jihadists, and the Islamists
are the extreme element
of mainstream Muslims.
So who are the mainstream
normal Muslims?
And that's what I really
try to bring out in the book
that there is this vast
belly of 1.8 billion Muslims
around the world.
Most of whom wake
up in the morning--
I mean, I don't
have the numbers.
But most of whom
pray first thing
in the morning for
divine blessings.
Most of whom recite Quran
or listen to the Quran.
I know that because when I
was in the Middle East living,
before [INAUDIBLE] came on or
[? Tarkan's ?] music came on
on midday, for
about the first hour
or so in the shops in
the malls, you have
beautiful recitations of Quran.
It used to be beautiful,
melodious, almost
opera like the
recitation of the Quran.
The Ottomans and
others that mastered,
you listen to the prayer
call in either Istanbul
or in other parts of
the Muslim world that
hasn't been influenced
by extremism,
is very melodious
and intentionally so.
And you go into
the mosque, you see
the architecture, the
calligraphy exceptionally
beautiful designed out of love,
love to venerate the divine.
And then in their
daily pursuits,
most Muslims will say
inshallah to mean God willing,
mashallah as God wills,
and [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],,
or praise be to God.
There's a connection
between our lived reality
and the divine realm.
Now amid all of
that, Muslims also
engaged in trade and
secular engagement
and living their lives.
But the vast majority
of things used
to be, and for the vast
majority of Muslims to this day
continues to be, halal.
Everything is
permissible for us,
except the few things that have
been forbidden, so whether it's
pork or for most Muslim drinking
alcohol and other matters.
But we've tilted
now to the other way
around where everything is
forbidden unless it's permitted
in the extremists world view.
Now who are the Sufis?
I try to bring out great
examples of Muslim luminaries
of the past.
Probably the best known among
Muslims is Mevlana Rumi,
but also known in
the West as Rumi.
But I give an
example of that love
from very early on in Islam.
And Rabia al-Adawiyya, who used
to be a Muslim female teacher
in Basra, today's Basra in Iraq,
in the southern part of Iraq,
there's a famous story
among Muslim scholars
that one day she
was caught walking
with a torch of fire in one
hand and a bucket of water
in the other.
And others asked, what
is it that you're doing?
It's a symbolic story.
It's a metaphor,
but it's powerful.
And what are you looking for?
She said, I'm looking to
burn heaven when I find it.
I want to burn heaven.
And I want to put out
the fires of hell,
so that people love
God for God's sake,
and not because they're fearful
of going and burning in heaven
or they want the
joys of paradise.
And this is eight century.
This is very early on
that being driven by love.
And Rabia, she was very famous
for her mystical inclinations.
And now her students
and the students
of others, Mevlana Rumi,
Hafez, ibn 'Arabi all
of those great Muslim
luminaries are there.
But I will end very briefly
by talking about, I mean,
I'm just spot for choices
to who I refer to.
I mean, whether it's Ibn 'Arabi,
Hafez, Omar Khayyam, Mevlana
Rumi, his teacher,
Shams Tabrizi.
Elif Shafak's books
have done a great job
in reviving some of that.
I mean, Rumi is the most famous.
So I'll just give
a quick example
of why Mevlana Rumi was
drawn to his teacher,
and the book goes into
great detail about Rumi.
But Rumi's important
because the Ottoman Empire
was built on his teachings.
So for 700 years, you
had an entire empire
that was built on the teachings
of love and dedication
and compassion and
coexistence that was came out
of Mevlana Rumi's teachings.
And to this day,
the Turks and those
in their sphere of influence
in Syria or in the Balkans
talk about Rumi as Mevlana.
And he was called
Rumi because he was
a Roman, a Byzantine citizen.
Came to Konya because
of Genghis Khan,
and his massacres in
Afghanistan and the Muslim East
at the time.
Again, these are all Muslim
incidents of history.
Some of them are metaphysical.
Many of them metaphysical.
In the modern age, it's hard
to believe some of them.
But the act of
belief is just that.
It's a belief.
We don't have to bring
Newtonian physical evidence
to illustrate it.
But it's a Muslim
belief that Mevlana Rumi
in the 1200s and his father were
both very prominent teachers
in Konya and professors of
Sharia as law and advisors
to the Celtic monarch who
was based out of Konya.
So Rumi's entire life was based
on very hard Quranic evidence
based life that we
have to be pious.
We have to worship God.
We have to avoid punishment.
And we have to be
kind and compassionate
because texts say so.
So he was an
adherent of the text.
And he applied it
to the context.
And again, in and of
itself, not a problem.
But he then, as he's
teaching one day in Konya,
he's sitting beside a
well, and his students
are asking him questions on
Quranic exoduses, commentary
on hadith.
And a wandering
dervish from Persia
called Shams from
Tabriz, a city in Iran,
comes along and pushes
his book into the well.
And Rumi jumps, saying,
this is the only manuscript
I have of this book.
How dare you throw
it into the well.
Who are you?
You have no idea
what it is I'm doing.
I'm teaching the law of God.
Wandering tramps are
too many in this city.
Get rid of them.
And as an advisor to the
monarch, what he said
was taken seriously.
And his students were all there
in awe of this great teacher.
At that point, the
wandering dervish
jumps, bends down into the
water, takes out the book,
and passes it back to Rumi.
And Rumi looks at
the book and says,
what's the point in
you giving it to me?
Although I'm impressed how
you got the book out of water.
But I'm sure the ink
is now wiped out.
Shams says, open the book.
Have a look.
Rumi opens the book, and
the ink is still intact.
And Rumi at that point asks
Shams, what is it that you know
and what is it that
you do that allows
you to work these miracles?
And then Shams say,
this is something
that you will not understand.
As you claim I don't
understand your law,
I am firmly convinced
you Rumi will not
understand what I've just done.
So he begs Shams, take me.
Teach me.
Make me a mystic in your path.
And then there's a long story,
and Rumi become the founder
of the whirling dervishes.
That most people in
the world at least
are familiar with the
dance that comes out
of the whirling dervishes.
He was the founder of
that Sufi tradition.
That's been with us
now for 800 years.
And most Muslims
are followers of one
of these great mystics, whether
it's Rumi of the Mevlana order,
whether it's the Qadirs,
Abdul Qadir Gilani of Baghdad,
whether it's the
Naqshbandis, Baha-ud-Din
Naqshband from Central
Asia, whether it's
the Chishtis from Moinuddin
Chishti in Delhi in India,
and whether it's
Imam [INAUDIBLE] that
came out of North Africa.
The list is long.
The list is a very, very long.
But that's not
where our focus is.
Because what bleeds, leads.
The terrorists attack in France.
Tomorrow's news headlines
all about terrorism.
But the lived reality
of Muslim life
is something entirely different.
So I've tried to bring some
of that out in the book.
And I encourage you to
read it and recommend it.
And I've used up my time.
So with your permission,
we'll open to questions.
SPEAKER: We've got
time for questions.
So if you want to put your hands
up, and I will start us off.
I think just the way you've
structured your book,
it's about answering
questions that people have
and sharing information,
trying to meet ignorance
with information.
Aside from a book that
answers those questions,
there must be more
that needs to be
done to get people across
the world to understand
what it is to be a Muslim.
Do you have any answers
to how that's done?
How should that information
be put out there?
ED HUSAIN: That's
a great question.
I think for most people who
live with and among Muslims--
by the way, most
people in the world
probably don't, so you're
right to ask that question.
Those who do know that the
lived reality of living side
by side with Muslims isn't
as dangerous as often
portrayed in the media.
And for those in the
world who don't, I
think in a almost
self imposing way,
I would say that the
responsibility is
upon us as those of us who are
Muslims and those of us who
have relations
with our government
and religious leaders
to do one thing,
and that one thing is the
Khawarij, the extremists,
the jihadists who are expelled
from within Islam in the past
and done so repeatedly all
the way down to the end
of the Ottoman Empire, that
they ought to be expelled again.
So in the name of Islam and
God and protecting Muslims,
they don't take up arms
and kill innocent people
and destroy museums
and places of worship
and target Jewish people in
particular and Shia in Iraq.
The carnage that you're seeing
around the world, almost all
of it is led by that Khawarij,
extremist, jihadist thought.
The reaction of
Muslims today has
been to basically say, you
know, I'm not doing it.
It's not really my problem.
That's got to change.
And I think the onus
is on us as Muslims
to expel the Khawarij
from within us
as they were expelled
throughout history.
What that does then is I think,
the global media and others are
forced to respond to that,
and say that, there's
a global summit in
Mecca or elsewhere
where Muslim scholars, thousands
of them have to come together,
and say, the Khawarij
are not Muslims.
And they were expelled from
the house of Islam in the past,
and they're expelled again now.
So that helps I think to
reset the relationship.
And it also helps
young Muslims think,
if those guys from
ISIS in Syria and Iraq
that I want to go and
join from Bethnal Green,
if they're being expelled by
the global Muslim community
and its leadership
in Mecca, even if I
do want to go and join them,
god forbid, what it does
is puts a degree of
doubt in your mind.
And once you have doubt in
the minds of the extremists,
you can't do what it
is they want to do.
And that's a wider argument.
Because a suicide
bomber, by the way,
has to have [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
is called complete religious
certainty that what he's doing
or she's doing is done for God
and is done to enter paradise.
Unless you have that
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],,
you can't do that action.
So just by doing
what I'm suggesting,
I put that in the
book the kind of need
to expel extremists
from the fold of Islam,
you help the rest of
the world understand
the normative mainstream
peaceful message of Islam
but also you prevent extremists
from walking that pathway.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
That was a really
interesting talk.
You described the Islamism as
the difference between things
that are forbidden and permitted
elevated to state levels.
They're legal or illegal.
To what extent is there
a social pressure or can
a social pressure develop along
those lines which effectively
makes it law, law
for a community,
because there is so
much social pressure?
And we can see it across
other religions, as well.
We can use the phrase good
Christian or good Muslim
or good Hindu not
from the perspective
of what a person does in
their engagement with society,
but whether they follow
the requirements.
Do I go to church on Sunday?
Do I cover my head as a female?
And the social pressure,
it seems sometimes
that it can be almost as
much as a state requirement,
because people then feel
compelled to follow it.
How much of that do you see?
And do you see that
clean line between those
that feel it should be
state law and those that
don't necessarily say that,
but there is enough societal
pressure within a group that
effectively makes it something
that people within that
society feel they have to do?
ED HUSAIN: Yeah.
That's another great question.
And as you were
asking the question,
I was thinking
about East London,
but I was also thinking
about Egypt, the largest
Arab Muslim country.
And the same applies in
Indonesia as a background
answer to your question.
20, 25 years ago in almost
all of those countries,
and even here in London,
Birmingham, Bradford,
the social pressure
element wasn't there
among Muslim communities.
But that has now emerged.
Clearly it's not
the law of the land
here to, you know, whether
it's enforcing the headscarf
or whether it's expecting
adherence to religious laws,
but that's now the norm.
I mean, it's a great
source of sadness
that young girls in
schools in London aged 3,
4, onwards, many Muslim girls
are now wearing headscarves.
But there's nothing, as you
say, in law that expects it.
But in Muslim countries,
the Islamist movements
want to do exactly
that, make it law.
But you're absolutely right
that even without making
it law on university
campuses across Egypt,
if anyone here is from
Egypt or has been in Egypt,
you'll notice that.
20 years ago that
was not the norm.
But now social
pressure is such that--
I'm not picking on women.
I'm not picking on hijab.
It's just a visible
manifestation
of that social
application of pressure
to adhere to an
interpretation, by the way, not
the interpretation,
an interpretation
of Quranic dress code that
goes back to biblical times.
So you're right.
Social pressure is
on the increase.
And social pressure, almost
the shame element, the honor
element, the fact that
if you're not doing this,
you're somehow an outcast, that
you're somehow a moral pariah
can often lead to
people adhering to that.
But there's also good news.
And that good news sadly comes
in the form of hypocrisy.
The more you enforce,
the more people rebel.
There's a beautiful saying
in Arabic, [SPEAKING ARABIC]
that which is forbidden
becomes more desired.
So the more whether it's
a social pressurizing
Islamists and the
law enforcing cousins
want to impose, people rebel.
And you're seeing that
in Iran now where women
are making the removal
of their headscarf
a symbol of resistance.
But here, you know, a couple
of my friends in Tower Hamlets
were counselors.
And they said to me-- this
was about four years ago.
I don't know the rates
now-- but that the highest
rates of abortion in all London
boroughs was in Tower Hamlets
among teenage pregnancy
and teenage abortions.
The question is why is it that
young girls in Muslim majority
schools in Tower Hamlets
are having abortions?
Because they've been forced
to lead double lives.
And that's the
beauty of freedom.
You give people
freedom, they choose
whatever it is, the form of
life they want to choose.
You take away that
freedom, you impose
with it social mores
based religiosity or legal
religiosity, you have extremism
and hypocrisy being bred.
So in reaction to
your question, you're
absolutely on to something.
Even without it being state
law, the desire to make it
state law by those
movements, the desire
to impose that as state
law has led to them having,
the Muslim Brotherhood
in particular, having
so much influence on
the Arab public space
that it's almost a statement
that we don't have the law.
But in the absence of the
law, we will uphold the law.
So there might be
another element to that,
especially in Arab countries,
extreme secularism being
imposed, whether it was
in Tunisia also in Turkey.
You just made me
think about that.
I think that stands
up to scrutiny.
One of the reasons why Egypt and
Turkey both became so Islamic
was that they were opposing
the government elite.
And the government
elite were imposing on
them French laicite.
Ataturk was renowned
in Turkey in the 1920s
for imposing French
laicite on the people,
abolishing headscarves.
If you wore a headscarf
in Turkey or in Egypt,
you could not work
in government.
You could not be a
television presenter.
You could not go to
university in Turkey.
And I've got tons of
friends who, you know,
could not go to university
in Turkey in the 1990s.
So a reaction against that was
two fingers to the government.
So it also becomes a form
of rebellious politics.
Apply that to here
in the UK, we might
be seeing something
similar play out in France.
Something similar play
out, you know, Jack Straw
says that women should
not be wearing their face
veil in 2002 or 2003.
And then you suddenly see a
surge of women wearing that.
A last reflection on
your great question
is in many ways many,
many Muslim women--
I'm not mansplaining, but it's
just an observation-- many,
many Muslim women feel and
think from conversations
I've had with them is that
it's a form of Islamic feminism
to be able to cover
completely, and say no man
can view any element of me
is a form of feminism now.
You or I can disagree with
that or agree with it.
But that's also
another component
to that that leads to what
you're observing rightly
as a social manifestation
of that rigidity.
AUDIENCE: I've got a
follow up question actually
to what Manesh asked and
what you've been saying.
One of those features of
these extremist groups,
whether they're the ones
that you've referenced,
or in any religion really, the
extremist group's are always
characterized by an adherence
to really strict rules.
And it seems like
that is what attracts
younger men,
stereotypically, which
is someone who is attracted
to an extremist group
tends to be a younger man.
And it's almost surprising
sort of contrary
to what a lot of parents
would think a 17-year-old boy
would be attracted to is a very
strictly regulated society.
Most 17 year old
boys you would expect
would be wanting to
run off and do whatever
they want without any rules.
But it seems like there is
some appeal from that rigor.
So have you thought
about there's
a way of harnessing that
and using it for good?
That there's something about
this rigidity that appeals?
And how do we counter that?
ED HUSAIN: You're
absolutely right.
And there are reasons why
that rigor of right, wrong,
do, don't, hell, heaven,
black, white, appeals.
And in the Middle
East, in particular, I
have a very clear explanation.
And it was borne out two years
ago by a report the British
Council brought out.
Now in the 1950s and
1960s, Gamal Abdel Nasser,
the Egyptian
president at the time,
wanted to nationalize
his country.
And he brought large
numbers of workers
from the Egyptian rural villages
and agricultural agrarian
workers into the city.
Their children then decided
to want to move up the ladder,
and they all trained to
become doctors and engineers.
When I say all, I'm
talking 85%, 90%
of young Egyptians
at universities
want to become either a doctor
or an engineer or lawyers
too, but generally
doctor and engineer.
Now by the '80s
and '90s, what you
had is large numbers
of students who
were either medical doctors
or mechanical engineers.
Those students were
exposed to these trade
unions that were dominated
by the Muslim Brotherhood.
So they were given the
Quran to read as a manual.
There was no nuance, poetry,
context, history, consequence.
This is what you do,
and that's the result.
You know, you do x, y,
and z, you go to heaven.
You do a, b, c, you go to hell.
You create an
entire society based
on that very rigid
application of that worldview.
Now look at the British
Council's report,
it bears it out.
Look at almost every
single terrorist leader,
Ayman al-Zawahiri, a doctor,
Osama bin Laden, an engineer,
[INAUDIBLE] leader [INAUDIBLE]
an engineer, [INAUDIBLE] leader
here in the UK, a doctor.
You keep going, you know,
the previous Hamas leader,
a doctor, the previous leader
of the Muslim Brotherhood,
Mohammed Badie, a doctor,
a vet, but a doctor.
It just keeps going.
Now what that tells you
is that mindset of right,
wrong, do, don't, heaven, hell.
So that I think is the--
now why does it happen
in other societies?
Why does it happen
here in the West?
Why are teenagers drawn to that?
Because, yes, there's
a rules based element,
but there is something
else at play here.
It gives you the
global cool factor.
Who wants to be a gang
member on the street corner
when you can be a
global terrorist?
You know, you blow up
stuff, and then you're
in an evening news for
three days in a row.
You're trending
all over Twitter.
There is a cool factor
at play here, I'm afraid,
and you see that in the
affiliation of young Muslims.
Because if you're asking
them to join their parents
form of Islam, which
is very mystical,
love based, oriented towards
the divine, and very private,
and love for God, and
dedication to humanity,
that all sounds so
boring and moderate.
And moderation by
definition isn't exciting
if you're a teenager.
But, you know, if you're
anywhere near extremist groups,
immediately you will have the
government's prevent agenda
on your door.
You know, how cool is that the
local authority and the police,
people are knocking
on your door,
but they can't arrest
you, because you
haven't said or done anything.
So I think there is the
global cool factor associated
with extremism and terrorism.
You know, but there is
also something else.
And I'll put that on the
table, and you can decide.
In Egypt I saw this
after the Arab Spring.
I see it here in the UK.
In addition to the kind of
black and white worldview
and the excitement and the cool
factor, especially in Salafi
circles, what you
immediately have access
to as a 17, 18, 19, 20, 24,
25-year-old young Salafi man,
or a woman, but
especially for Salafi men,
is access to the opposite
gender and sanctioned by faith.
So if you're not a Salafi,
and if you have access,
if you're dating, or if you're
sleeping out of wedlock,
it's considered to be sinful.
And therefore,
people have a kind
of moral compunction about it.
But if you're Salafi,
all you do is, you know,
you're attracted to
sister so and so.
It's weirdly
incestuous, but that's
what they call each
other, brother and sister.
But then you just
go to the imam,
and you have two witnesses,
male witnesses, ordinarily
your friends.
And then you do an [INAUDIBLE]
an exchange of vows,
and then you're basically
allowed to date and sleep.
All these various
kind of marriages
are very popular in
Egypt, very popular,
increasingly in Turkey too.
But if you move among the
younger population there,
and if you're a young
17-year-old Abdul in Cairo,
your life has a
whole new meaning.
It has global resonance.
And there's the cool factor, but
you're also applying scripture.
And then, you know,
your sexual life
is healthier than the
average Egyptian who
has to wait until
he's 35, have a house,
have enough money saved up, buy
a car, and then get married.
You know, it's hard
for most Egyptians
who are living on $3 a day.
It's very hard.
But if you're Salafi, almost
all of those needs are taken.
Because it's a
different lifestyles.
It's different.
Anyway.
So I hope that
answers your question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for that talk.
I just wanted one
point when you said
that empires lead to creation
of this kind of totalitarian
ideology.
We're in right now in the
capital of a big empire
that also dissolved, but
there was no rebuttal.
And I think it's because
the empires it mentioned--
Russia.
I'm from Russia.
A German, they were
very totalitarian.
They didn't allow whatever
views were included
in the public discourse,
whereas British Empire was kind
of a democracy, so you
could have included everyone
and the process was functioning.
And my question to
you was what ended
the Christian theological
totalitarianism was
enlightenment when there was
the great thinkers and education
and great progress in
science and so on and so on.
Do you see that happening
in the Muslim world?
Did it happen before?
Will it happen sometime
soon that we'll
end the kind of totalitarianism
and these fringes of Islamism?
ED HUSAIN: Repeat the last.
A great question.
The last part was is there
an enlightenment process
in the Western world?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Do you think it's
already happened,
or is it coming, or
are we kind of we
in the process of enlightenment,
or is it still kind of needs
to be worked on?
ED HUSAIN: Yeah.
There are various
answers to that.
The first answer is that
early Muslims led the way
for the European Enlightenment.
And while that's reassuring,
and you can find the evidence
for that, whether it's
Farabi or whether it's
Ibn Tufail and his
focus on empiricism,
whether it's the influence
on Thomas Aquinas,
or whether it's Ibn
[INAUDIBLE] or [INAUDIBLE]
and their influence
on Latin scholars,
and the way in which the free
inquiry and the free thought
spread in Spain and then
to Paris and through Paris
on to thinkers at
Oxford and Cambridge,
or whether it's even John
Locke and his influence
through Muslim scholars
and his teacher
Edward Pocock at Cambridge
who was taught in Aleppo,
I mean, there's a lot there
that many Muslims point
to that early Arab
scholars, especially
in Spain and in Cordoba,
were the pioneers of empiricist
free mind free inquiry
based mind.
And that can be proven
from Farabi down.
The problem is that then
forces many Muslim thinkers
to rest on their laurels.
They say, oh yeah, we
created the enlightenment.
That's the intellectual
risk of the complacency.
And I don't think
most people are even
familiar with that genealogy.
John Gray and others
write about it.
I mean, Leo Strauss is
a big advocate of it.
But most are not familiar.
But in the Muslim world,
there is this inherent,
arrogance is too strong
a word, but almost
a claim that we
were the first moves
in the European Enlightenment.
So now that Europe saw
the enlightenment, I mean,
I honestly don't
see that coming.
I'll tell you why.
Because one of the
difficulties here
was for the early thinkers,
whether it was Voltaire or even
Spinoza, they were all outcasts.
And they were all punished.
Rousseau certainly, and John
Locke, I mean, lived in exile.
Hobbes lived in exile.
But now amid all of
that, what you had was,
yes, they lived in exile.
Yes, they were persecuted.
But they left intellectual
legacies behind.
They wrote big powerful books
and put ideas out there,
that over the course
of 200 or 300 years
led to something like
the French Revolution.
Now my worry is that the Arab
Spring was supposed to be that.
But you alluded to the
answer in your question.
When you don't have
societies in which there's
freedom to think, ask,
rebel, dissent, innovate,
it's hard for free
thinkers to emerge.
And in many ways, some of the
more authoritarian governments
in the Middle East have
learned the lessons
of what's happened here.
And I was in a
conversation yesterday,
and there was a person from
the Middle East in government,
you know, we don't want
feminism intersectionality
in our countries.
We don't want the
vast godless atheism
that you have in Europe.
You know, we don't
want to open the doors
to transsexual, pansexual,
identity complexity
that you have.
Now to me, that's not
a healthy response.
Because if that's the
individual's ultimate choice,
and that's where
they want to go,
unleash the battle of ideas, and
let people choose and decide.
So on the one hand,
there's complacency
that we give birth
to the enlightenment.
On the other hand,
there's a we don't
want to go down that
route, because you
have the individual liberty
going to an extreme.
In between what
we have is trying
to keep a lid on the status quo.
So from my point
of view, I honestly
don't see any great
revolutionary upheaval
that unleashes the individual
as has happened here.
But what I do see is a
much more Anglo Saon,
Burkeian slow burn going
forward towards reform
and restructuring and allowing
for societies to think freely.
But in the
foreseeable future, we
will not see small
European style democracies
or even liberal societies emerge
in most of the Middle East.
I think there will be
greater tumult. I think
there will be ever
more difficulty
and confrontation between
various denominations
and sects.
The Iraqi difficulties
haven't played out yet.
Turkey's not heading in
a positive direction.
Yemen on fire.
Libya broken apart.
Egypt beyond bankrupt.
Almost every Middle
Eastern country.
You know, before we go
to the next question,
it's just I focus
on the Middle East
because the future of Islam
isn't defined by Indonesia
or the large 200 million
strong Muslim community
in India or Muslims in the west.
The beating heart
of the Muslim world
is still Mecca, Medina,
the Gulf, Egypt, Damascus.
And almost all of
those countries
are in deep identity crises
about their place in the world.
So sorry not to be
able to provide you
with an optimistic
answer, because I just
don't see it in the next
100 years, 150 years.
AUDIENCE: Again, thank you
for a really interesting talk.
I was struck by what you said
about love at the beginning
and that being at
the center of Islam,
and also a desire to emulate
good and emulate Muhammad.
And then we've gone on to talk
about various type of people
who want to follow Islam.
But I feel that we've kind of
not touched on the God of Islam
and what His view is
and what His heart is.
And my thinking is
that that should inform
how these people are behaving.
So I was interested
to get your thoughts.
And it's a huge question.
But if you can explain how
you think God views people,
and that should go
to explaining why we
have people doing what they do.
ED HUSAIN: You've got
great minds here at Google.
Every question's been
really impressive.
Every question's
I'm struck by how you phrased
the question, the God of Islam.
There was a gentleman
yesterday at an event who said,
the Muslim God.
Most Muslims, every
Muslim around the world
will say we have the same
God as Christians and Jews.
And some Muslims would go
further in India and say,
you know, Hindus ultimately
worship a great god
and that great God is Allah.
I mean, the Mughals
used that for 200 years,
Akbar onwards to justify a
Muslim presence in India.
So I mean, the god in our
world is the God creator.
I recognize many people
who are atheists do not
believe in the God created
thesis, but believe
in some kind of divine force,
some kind of first mover,
some kind of beginner,
some kind of primal force
in the universe
that makes it spin.
Whichever version of God,
there's something beyond us.
There's the physics, and
there's the metaphysics.
It's that metaphysics that
most Muslims are interested in.
Now in the seventh
century world of Arabia,
that was referred to Allah.
The Jews, Christians,
and pagans at the time
recognized that God as
being the same ultimate god.
In Muslim theology, that
Allah was our creator,
and that Allah has
expectations of us.
Of, you know, there's a
beautiful verse in the Quran.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] All of you
are tried to see which of you
is best in action.
So there's a focus on
doing good and acting well,
and life is a trial,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] to see
which of you is best in action.
So that's the Islamic
or the godly expect,
the God of Quran, the
God of the Old Testament,
the New Testament, I think
too, is behind our creation
and wants to see that our
conduct reflects goodness.
And, yes, in the Quran
there are references
to goodness in this
world is rewarded
with heaven in the next world.
Evil in this world is punished
with hell in the next world.
Now both heaven, hell in the
Quran is eternal existences.
Our next life is everlasting,
and this life is temporal.
I think that's the gist
of what God expects of us.
Now one of the beauties
I find in the Quran
is that God has around
99 attributes or names.
And I'd encourage you
to go look those up,
you know, the 99 names of God.
Almost all of them are
deeply beautiful names.
You know, there's a great
saying of the prophet Muhammad
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] that surely
God is beautiful and loves
beauty.
And the Quran verses, surahs
they're called the chapters,
all of them but one,
113 of them start saying
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] in the
name of God, most compassionate,
most merciful.
And that's the God of Islam
and the God of most Muslims.
And I think unlike
Jews and Christians,
Muslims recognize all
the Jewish prophets
and recognize Jesus
not as the Son of God,
but as a prophet of God.
But Christians and Jews,
and Muslims forever
have this complaint,
they don't recognize us,
because they don't recognize
Muhammad as a prophet of God.
Because he was an Arabian
prophet, and he could not be.
But those are intra and
interfaith based debates
that I think will
continue forever.
But ultimately, it's that
one God who is Allah,
and a focus on the one God.
The extreme
manifestation of that
is that the extremists
take that one God
obsession to a whole new level.
So that one God must have one
law applicable to all people,
and any other aberration
has got to be obliterated.
That's the problem with
taking good ideas, noble ideas
to this excess.
Hence, their focus with
applying their version
of the one law on
all people globally
and their reading of Sharia.
Hope that answers your question.
SPEAKER: I think that's
all we've got time
for in terms of questions.
So thank you very
much for coming, Ed.
That was fascinating.
ED HUSAIN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]